[Music]
uh
so what's going on i i've seen that
that opie's been talking about rogan
what is that about because anthony was
on rogan's show recently right
yeah last week yeah yeah and he was like
rogan would be easy to beat
what does that even mean well that
pulled up from a few months ago
okay yes what happened was opie was
talking about if he really took this
podcasting thing seriously
he could overtake rogan in popularity
and one reason why
the reason why because i pulled these
clips it was amazing that he said this
the reason why he thinks that is because
he once went after howard stern
and almost got as popular as howard
stern
so i'm like wait a second you can
overtake rogan
but you weren't able to beat stern and
you don't have the cast around you
anymore so what are you talking about
yeah you were never almost as big as
stern you
anthony and jimmy right as a unit
were almost as big as staring at one
right because as soon as it became
opie radio it was no longer on in the
mornings anymore it was no longer drive
time radio like i will put you in the
afternoon it's fine well you know what
you know why they almost beat him but
never did because howard had that
powerhouse stuttering
john there and how do you compete with
that
and uh this is opie's response opie
pushes back against the ona lies in
garbage all right let's see here let's
see let's
i'll tell you right now merce already
loves the beginning of this video
[Music]
why is he doing that but i hate him so
much i i hate him can i tell you why
hmm so what's the name of that stupid
song the seven
seven nation army yeah seven nation army
plays at a lot of [ __ ]
games for some reason he's decided
that's his new theme song
even though it's in every arena it's
overused all over the place but that's
the opie song
so he would sing that when he used to do
the show with carl ruiz when he had the
podcast on westwood one
and carl always hated it so coral reefs
would go boop
boop boop boop tell opi like shut up and
stop it and nobody's like oh yeah that's
funny i'll do that now
because opie's never in on the [ __ ]
joke he's a [ __ ]
um that's uh this is so now he's
fighting but now remember
my favorite story and i'm sure you
covered it carl but one we covered it on
the show a couple weeks ago when he said
he ran into the gym
they're totally totally real story about
running into
jimmy i saw you guys talking about that
it's [ __ ] hilarious
he just ran into jimmy he ran into him
and he was like yuck
and jim first off that that happened
i'll tell you something about jimmy
jimmy would have absolutely talked about
it
all right he wasn't not gonna talk about
it and then everyone's like so what did
jimmy say he's like i don't know i was
too busy laughing
that story none of it was logical at all
like he remembers certain things vividly
and other things he has no idea
so this is uh this is i'll be talking
about all the all the haters
lies from the compound oh my god what is
this
hold on pause it real quick sure i want
to point out this
is a rare opie youtube video that is
edited do you see that cut right there
yep they typically someone's working on
this behind the scenes with them he
doesn't want to do that so
apparently this is all the stuff that he
wanted to leave in the program
all right so let's keep that in mind so
this is the best of the best this is
like
best of opie highlights highlights got
it
i don't uh i don't uh i don't listen to
anthony or anybody at the compound so i
wouldn't know if they're doing uh lies
throwing lives at me
butters knows about the anthony rant he
was fielding haters and blocking people
afterward lol
you guys are having your own
conversation why don't you let me in on
this
i have no idea that sounds like every
opiate anthony episode everyone's having
their own conversations
in her monologue and hoping all the big
greats in there
so can i tell you who butters is this is
this guy named creamy butters
and what creamy butters does is he's the
moderator on the facebook group the pod
squad
what's the pod squad that's opie's
facebook group and it's a bunch of
storks the podcast why
can i just say that there isn't a word
in any western language that can
really underscore how much i [ __ ]
hate the pod squad and anybody that's
associated with it
uh did you see anthony's recent video
about you he says you should have
continued on a with him
when he got fired oh tell him to go [ __ ]
himself
i mean you could tell him the only show
was dead way before he got fired he
turned our whole
show into one big racist gun talking
rant but there was no what
is that really does he believe that
that's a good question because i'm
wondering sometimes if he just says
things to defend himself or if he really
believes that that's what it was
i think he believes it's because it is
true to an extent but
it still was an intact functioning show
like he's right to a certain extent
today he did kind of start spiraling and
he was
you know kind of started losing a little
bit of his humor and stuff but
it was still good and they were still
making lots of money
it was still my favorite show that was
not you know i listened to them every
morning in 2014
and uh when anthony got fired i was like
uh
[ __ ] i gotta go back to stern damn it
it's funny because you know people that
i know
that that work that work there like even
people that were loyal to opie all told
me the same thing they were like
he he kept saying oh you guys are my
guys thanks for staying loyal you know
when anthony left and then
and then after opie got fired for
filming bobo in the bathroom
they were like uh it was roland rollins
sorry rolling in the bathroom they're
both
and i confused them rolling in the
bathroom
they were like uh management then after
opie left because they weren't
protecting anymore like yeah you know he
kept filing complaints about you
and about you and he was filing
complaints to management about you
and they're like what do you what we
were loyal to him we were defending the
guy
and it barely threw everybody under the
bus yeah
this episode that you're playing right
here is amazing
because he's talking about
he's answering these questions of things
that anthony said that he didn't say so
people are lying to him they're trolling
him of course
so he's responding to these things and
he's got it in his head we'll get to it
but he's got it in his head
that no one got along with each other
that anthony hated erock and erock hated
sam
and sam hated jim he's got all these
scenarios cooked up
he doesn't know any of these people and
it's all projecting
he's the one who hated everybody he was
trying to get them fired behind the
scenes yep
everybody was trying to get everybody
fired everyone yes
which is insane to me oh won't be an
anthony sorry good
well you got to throw people under the
bus you know things aren't working out
well
you don't want them pointing at you so
you're like well yeah our [ __ ]
producer
erock we gotta get rid of him he's
[ __ ] up the show
the only guy who has been since day one
defending opie he literally called opie
his hero
you know yup show anymore to tell him to
go [ __ ] himself enough already
and he's gonna he's gonna uh make
believe he wasn't building a whole
goddamn studio in the basement of his
house and it had nothing to do with me
but he wasn't pretending he wasn't doing
that no he was very open that he was
building building in my house
yeah he was building the studio which i
actually did a show once um
he never [ __ ] turned it into
competing [ __ ] or whatever
he's not like he turned them into
competing [ __ ] um
it's not like he was going like oh i'm
starting my own thing like
that didn't happen till he got fired he
just was like over there [ __ ] around
and he had the money and
yeah honestly him building that studio
in his house was probably the only
healthy thing he spent his money on
don't think about this though
this video is entitled pushing back
against o a lies
he just made up something that anthony
has never said
would never say oh he's gonna pretend he
wasn't building a studio
what are you talking about he was going
on live we you guys would talk about on
the on a show
he's not pretending that he should have
done the stern thing and built an exact
replica so you can lie to him
like no i've been going into the studio
to do that would have been amazing
anthony posted a clip saying you lied
about the big serious comic story but he
clearly just
misheard what you said i absolutely
didn't lie i i'm
i'm done with fake news i'm done with
people [ __ ] bashing me with fake
[ __ ] and fake [ __ ] stories the fact
is and it should be a compliment and he
should be uh
you know trying to blow himself tonight
the fact is when
anthony got fired they wanted to
continue uh
with the giant audience we had which was
absolutely [ __ ] dwindling way before
anthony got fired
and hold on stop it right there opie
always wants it both ways
we had a giant audience which was
dwindling because anthony sucks
okay but it was still massive yeah it
was still huge though
he's like the only show was dead we had
a giant audience
okay thought okay this guy
and i really want to say his name and i
know eventually i will i'm hoping he
says it
uh you know they kind of came to me and
said
who's been working out who who do you
think you could uh work with and i gave
a few names and then
one of these guys they were very very
interested in and they offered him a
million dollars
to do the show with me and they thought
that would be a a great way to
sound like he's whining i know doesn't
it like sound like whiny like
listen we're gonna do show me who was
this fake guy that they offered a
million dollars to because didn't they
only offer patrice like 37 when they
were trying to get seriously
they offered do they offer patrice 37
and some
pi and some watermelon jolly ranchers
so uh what anthony said was he thought
it was jim brewer
siriusxm was begging me to do
uh the show begging they were on their
hands and knees they were like opie i'll
suck your
[ __ ] dick right here in front of this
entire boardroom
that's how bad we we need you to step up
brother
everything with this guy is exaggerated
when he's talking about management
at syria so anthony pointed this out on
his show he was telling these stories
he's like i don't know where opi comes
up with this [ __ ]
we would go to the management and say
hey we want to do this bit and they'd
say
we talked to the attorneys they said you
can't do it opiate got in the air the
next morning and be
like they told us if we tried to do that
bit they'd
run us out of here they were screaming
at my face
about doing this bit now there's like
what is this guy talking about one of
them grabbed my wife's tits
no none of that happened hey hey hey hey
leave bob
i was going to make the same bandmark
god damn it butted heads there carl
i was going to say what are they
familiar look dude even if i [ __ ] her
i would never remember
bro i'm sorry dude
with all these a-listers people i never
knew
uh never met before oh a-listers here we
go
vic henley and charade again
billy on the street was one of them and
i'm like hey we've never met
b he's never been on my show see why the
[ __ ] would he do a radio show with me
when he's got this huge tv thing that's
really really working but i'm sure you
were talking them out of all these great
ideas
why would they want to work with little
because one thing opie always is he's
humble
and clearly i'm sure he communicated to
all these people
i have a feeling it was the other way
around opie i have a feeling
that you were constantly going what if
we got like brewer or what have we got
and they were like
you know he doesn't you know and then
brewer probably said i don't want to
work with this guy and then
people had to go back and go oh he's
busy with the metallica thing
that's what happened opie you were
probably this was this whole story is
happening in reverse in my opinion it's
you going
okay but what about like what if we got
colin quinn or something and
like colin quinn doesn't want to go to
anything every day yeah he's making
he's making it sound like brewer was
filling in for drums for metallica like
you know he's like
he had to be on tour with them he
couldn't possibly
that was sirius xm's uh mentality they
always
needed a big [ __ ] name uh they always
just
wanted uh radio shows with a-listers and
they thought okay
now that anthony's gone we'll uh we'll
team opio with some
[ __ ] a-lister and i'm like but i
don't have chemistry with any of these
people
i know any anybody or anyone or any
other human being
a human being in in his mind chemistry
is
someone who tells the funny jokes on the
show i need someone with chemistry you
know
you know tells the jokes yeah no no
chemistry's not a word another word for
material
right i i need someone to do the heavy
lifting
well i will i go lady trucker what's up
lady trucker
and you're so miserable about it and
it's like i would have given anything to
make three million dollars a year to sit
back while anthony and jimmy did all the
work
he just needed not to complain he would
have been fine
[ __ ] people and then at that point
i'm like i just want to do
the show with this new guy carl guy
fieri's a good friend
right hand man god oh my god if i hear
another carl [ __ ]
carl the chef story again also not to
mention the fact how many of these
[ __ ] people
how many of these underpaid poor [ __ ]
that worked for ona
um that that towards the end we're
producing
most of their material right so like so
it was like
you think about it from that perspective
i would kill for rotc to grow to the
point where we have it like
five [ __ ] we've like three interns
and five producers and they're just
bringing us [ __ ] all day i mean
you'll check out this piece of [ __ ]
media that so-and-so made we're just we
could just laugh at it
if only we if we if only we had these if
one of you had that right frozen
you still there right right frozen age
about that still there thank you frozen
you know what's crazy about that marsh
is um i'm not trying to name drop but i
was talking to anthony about this point
specifically oh name drop there it goes
and so listen to this they have all of
these producers
bringing them content and all the prep
that they need and
opi was ignoring it so what they would
do is they would give them the same prep
multiple days in a row to see if he ever
noticed and he never did because they're
like
why are we doing all this work let's see
if he's even paying attention to this
[ __ ]
and never did yeah like wouldn't you at
least look at everything everybody's
working on and go okay
today we'll do this one and this one and
i like this one and i
yeah i mean when you're the boss you're
not supposed to be breaking a [ __ ]
sweat but you are like
even carson would come in and go lose
that third joke on the monologue
uh add this joke to it and then instead
of this segment we're going to work in a
different segment because we're going to
do that that's all you got to do
also go back and go have a [ __ ] go
have coffee and wait
well also don't you want to give them
feedback so if there's [ __ ] they're
doing that you don't like like
stop doing this stuff but this stuff is
great instead
he was just [ __ ] coasting he was
literally not even looking at the prep
carl i've always believed in giving you
know employees feedback which is why
my way of giving them feedback is i go
behind their back to upper management
and then i complain
about them and then i have my upper
management come to them and say
hey man you really got to stop being
late every tuesday and wednesday i don't
know what you know and then
they go wow it's weird and i could go
well dude ain't me bad about the boss
must be noticing
you know what i mean so i guess maybe
try to be better about it
that's how i provide feedback carl that
is his strategy
i've been i've been meaning to tell you
uh it's not me it's coming from you know
i've been mad i've been meaning to tell
you frozen uh the boss has been saying
you've been doing a terrible job just to
let you know okay
yeah i apologize those guys are [ __ ]
thanks thank you those guys are real
pieces
sorry frozen it's not me you know what
does ben shapiro do that
like with though right he's real yeah
i'm like an unpaid intern
i'm sorry guys but you know we're owned
by the massage so it's not me but it's
the guys upstairs black cubes you know
how it is
it's not me folks